so Daniels got a really great background
you've been in medicine over 20 years
now it's been a long time since I was
five years old five year old just knew
you were playing doctor early on yeah
yeah yep and you've been with
singularity University ten years now as
a chair of medicine yeah since we
started in 2009 and we're here on that
we're here on the singularity University
campus at NASA Ames and Mountain View in
the heart of Silicon Valley yeah
you can check out su org for a lot of
the programs that happen here and as
she's amazing this place is just as
brilliant people roaming around I'm NASA
Ames is brilliant people wrote me around
Google's right here it's just the insane
conglomeration of epic people and then
you also were in you have an exponential
medicine conference so that's been
happening for seven years now yeah I'm
started 2011 I mean the brief synopsis
you know single era University focuses
on exponential technologies from AI
robotics 4d printing nanotech genomics
robotics how those impact the future and
how we can leverage those but obviously
a lot of the lens of technology can be
applied to health medicine from keeping
ourselves healthy health span longevity
to Diagnostics to therapy to clinical
trials to global health and so I started
exponential medicine here in 2011
because future health gives a bit of a
team sport and very often healthcare
meetings and conferences and the fields
in general very siloed and so it's a bit
of a synthesis crossing the spectrum and
asking what's the cutting edge and how
do we rethink and reinvent parts of
healthcare yes it's exponential medicine
counts got all the data and the
conference yep every every fall this
year will be November 4th through 7th at
the beautiful Hotel del Coronado in San
Diego which is amazing the oldest resort
in the west coast built in 1888 and it
was first electrified Hotel Edison
himself was there in like 1890 and it's
a pretty magical place by the beach to
try and get people out of their usual
mindsets and a lot of new ideas
companies collaborations have been
catalyzed there over the last few years
and again a lot of the videos or at
exponential medicine calm but it's been
kind of a surprising
synthesis of people who come together
there over the last several years we
hope to keep growing it yeah and like
you said you're tapping in
to genomics AI nanotech all these
different fields that are up and coming
exploding with the ease of technology
helping us and mashing them together in
order to figure out this beautiful human
body and how we can live longer live
healthier so alright let's talk about
one of your projects you've done so many
things but the marrow mine is really
interesting there's what the video is
explaining us online but why don't you
just give a quick explanation of what it
is sure well you know one of the lenses
when you're trying to innovate in
healthcare which is sometimes harder
than other fields given regulatory and
reimbursement in other elements is to
really in a problem an unmet need and so
I went to medical school Stanford went
away to Harvard came back for fellowship
I was doing a fellowship there in bone
marrow transplantation which we can talk
more about and I was also a part of the
first year of the Stanford Biodesign
program which is a really amazing
program started back in the early 2000s
and the lands there is what's an unmet
need and how do then you address and
innovate to create a new solution so I
was spending time as a bone marrow
transplant fellow in the operating room
harvesting bone marrow and where do we
normally harvest bone marrow from the
hip the iliac bone your hip bone yeah
usually you take a donor let's say god
forbid you had a brother sister with
leukemia and you were a match
genetically about a 25% chance of a
match in order in some cases to
hopefully cure folks from a disease like
leukemia we'll hit them with heavy dose
chemotherapy and radiation and then from
a magic donor ideally a sibling will
give them bone marrow to reboot their
immune system what goes into their hip
bone no it's simply an IV infusion the
bone marrow stem cells cause a matter of
what extent cells of which are about
0.2% of the cells in your bone marrow
are the ones that can make new red cells
white cells or platelets so when we do a
bone marrow transplant it's really a
form of stem cell transplantation we've
been doing for almost 50 years and it's
not as exciting as
transplanting marrow into your hip we
can take marrow which has those boomer
stem cells basically hang it up like a
blood transfusion into a patient has
gotten radiation and chemotherapy to
hopefully kill all their tumor cells if
they didn't get the bone marrow
transplant
their immune system their own stem cells
are knocked out and they would become
anemic and
for infection or a lot of red blood
cells so the bone marrow transplant is
that source of adult blood-forming stem
cells that can reboot the immune system
of that recipient sometimes you're gonna
be take your own Belmar stem cells and
do the similar thing to rescue yourself
after a big chemotherapy does so bottom
line my unmet need my pain point was
literally being in the operating room
spending an hour harvesting bone marrow
which you take a big needle you snuck
out about five milliliters of bone
marrow with each puncture through the
skin into the bone then it takes about
an hour the patient is under general
anesthesia because it's real otherwise
pretty painful we take about a liter of
bone marrow and then send it to the lab
and then they get shipped to their total
well that's a lot of peripheral blood
when you pull out marrow you're actually
the mayor was very well profused and
you're actually pulling what's a lot of
diluted marrow so we got it so the
inside of your hip bone maybe has a half
a liter but what ends up being is a bag
of it looks like a bag of blood and that
would be taken or shipped across the
world to where the boomer transplants
happening bottom line I must ask we
regenerate
yeah just like if you give a blood
transfusion your homeostatic mechanisms
you know up your red cells and platelets
and white cells after a after a blood
transition for example so you don't
really run out of bone marrow and we've
got it in our sternum and in our ribs
it's just at the hip bone it's a pretty
easy access spot
particularly to get a lot of marrow and
who do we know if we regenerate in a
healthy state will I be just as healthy
as I was before I gave yep there's been
a lot I don't have a donor you got me
heard about marrow drive someone might
have a patient who hasn't found a match
and they're going out and trying to get
people to become marrow donor so you
might send it a cheek swab it has cells
it could be analyzed for your HLA type
and we try and match folks and if you
were called up on the phone you could
donate bone marrow either by going to
the operating room like what you
described or in many cases taking a drug
called G CSF or annulus like colonies
stimulation factory which revs up your
bone marrow sends some of the stem cells
into your blood and you can do what's
called a phoresis
the challenge there's then you have a
lot more t-cells that when you
transplant that
recipient the patient in a higher risk
of something called graft-versus-host
disease your immune system from the
donor and the host are not the same so
there's sometimes a downside to some of
these immunologic therapies but bottom
line to zoom way back out you know here
was an old procedure harvesting boma it
hasn't changed in 40 years and I was
sort of thinking boy ma my hands tired
and the patient's the donor reran looks
a lot like Swiss cheese could there be a
better way and thinking about medical
devices I guess of a pocket engineer my
grandfather although an engineer thought
could we create almost a little bit
about roto-rooter that could go in the
marrow with one entry as opposed to a
hundred and stay inside the marrow
cavity and aspirate or suck out rich
marrow so to make a long story short
it's very flexible yeah it's a flexible
rotating device yes if you google daniel
craft and marrow miner and ted talk
you'll see a four minute description and
some other pieces or go to regen med
systems kind of that's the company we've
spun off to build that regen min systems
thomas has a good description bottom
line this is a way to enter the marrow
once and pull out a whole bunch of
marrow that's very rich in stem cell
content so created some early prototypes
tried them out and pigs and human
cadavers and eventually I got FDA
approval and into clinical trials and
were able to show that we could get out
a significantly higher number of stem
cells in a much less invasive way and
hopefully that will change the way we
harvest boomer stem cells for bone
marrow transplant but also now we're
using these adult stem cells which can
be the blood-forming stem cells as well
was what's called mesenchymal stem cells
or other progenitors in the marrow to
treat other diseases like heart disease
after someone might have had a heart
attack or as in heart failure there's
some still debate but clinical trials
that can show cells from your bone
marrow in certain preparations injected
back into the heart or into the leg if
you have bad blood supply can help
regrow blood vessels and improve
function and even survival so there's a
lot of interest in using stem cells from
the marrow or other places from fat or
we can talk about induced pluripotent
stem cells or embryonic stem cells as
as a source for regenerative medicine
which is a pretty broad field where we
look to repair replace or regenerate
tissues that are damaged from age
disease or trauma now with this new
technology why not have young people
that are maybe 18 20 however young we
cannot technically allow them to take on
a complex thing like being a bone-marrow
transplant
can they we you have to be donors for
people that are 40 years old and can we
rejuvenate them is that well there's a
question we all be a marrow donor for
somebody likely yes in most cases you
don't need to be a donor unless unless
we're waiting to get your marrow and
want it fresh there's the question you
would you want to bank your marrow now
when you're young and healthy for the
potential you might need it later you've
heard it like freezing crazy
you've heard of core blood banking so a
lot of babies are born today a lot of
folks decide or elect to pay a little
bit of money send the core blood from
the cords the the umbilical cord that
can then be collected and frozen away so
that if that child as a child or even an
adult has a problem like a leukemia or a
sibling has a genetic disorder or a
cancer they could be transported with
cord blood so that's now a pretty
significant way that we do essentially
blood stem cell transplantation as well
so with our minor device there's a
potential that you know in twenty
minutes or ten minutes with local
anesthesia we could Bank your marrow now
if you weren't banked when you were baby
with core blood we're even gonna launch
a project surely example we gonna
harvest marrow from organ donors who are
donating they're about deliver the
kidney because there's some amazing work
when you transplant a kidney or a liver
or other organs and you might combine
that with the same donor bone marrow and
the stem cells that are you can holler
eyes or have the patient against the new
heart kidney or liver have their immune
system recognize that as self is a big
challenge with organ transplantation is
that you have to be on anti-rejection
medicines steroids and other things that
can suppress your immune system and this
combination of solid organ transplant
with bone marrow from the same donor
might be a powerful approach so we can
harvest
press the immune system so that it
doesn't come back right new organ or the
new bone marrow the classic approach
used to call have you know donor cycles
some young healthy person would God
forbid have a motorcycle accident I have
a head injury which led rendered them
brain-dead but their organs were still
healthy so those would be at the past of
the family or sometimes if you were put
on your driver's license you want to be
an organ donor you may then donate your
organs to someone who might need them
someone in heart failure or a kidney
failure and it's life this life saving
but most of us are just based on blood
type match AOA B and you're not
immunologically identical so when you
receive an organ or even other tissues
from somebody else that's not you your
immune system will see that as foreign
and attempt to reject it so almost all
organ donor organ recipients unless they
get it from an identical twin require
immune suppression usually lifelong and
a lot of works going on at Stanford and
other places where I trained at Mass
General Hospital and many many parts are
in the world so I figured out how to
manipulate the immune system so you can
take an organ from another from a donor
and not be on immunosuppression which
gives you a risk of infection in other
elements how do you goes through that
that's by the sort of manipulation of a
bone marrow transplant on top of an
organ transplantation and so that
different there's different approaches
to timing and what cells you might use
but essentially it's the ability than to
like again a bone marrow transplant a
form of stem cell transplantation is
regenerating the blood and immune system
of the recipient so if I was gonna be a
trans donor to you when we took up my
bone marrow for my blood or my
peripheral blood and gave it to you
after we knocked out your own bone
marrow stem cells you would have Daniels
blood an immune system but it may not be
an exact match to the rest of your
system and your body would attempt to
reject it so that's what we try and
match donors and why we're often looking
particularly if someone might be born to
a an Asian mother and a European father
they have a more rare mix of immune
systems we we haven't have trouble
finding matches for them so I encourage
everybody to go out there and set up to
be part of a bone marrow registry it
doesn't it only takes a cheek swab and
then one day my kickball didn't get the
I think the honor and privilege of
helping save someone's life and you guys
have been researching this for so long
now and even fifty years ago is being
done in a more archaic way but that it
is completely safe for me to take a
fifth of my bone marrow and give it your
are like most of our physiology it's
pretty well-balanced and if you remove
some stem cells from your bone marrow
there's a bit of a some growth factors
and others are all through heat up and
more stem cells were generated the
definition of a stem cell by the way is
a cell that can regenerate itself so
make more blood-forming stem cells and
then also differentiate to turn into
progenitors and and white cells
platelets and other red cells so those
are those are adult stem cells we have
in our bone marrow we also have the
whole field of embryonic type stem cells
which you have only when you're sort of
at your eight-day embryo stage that have
the ability to turn into any tissue type
the adult stem cells giving your muscle
your bone or even your brain are usually
limited to a certain tissue type so bone
marrow stem cells or matter poetic stem
cells could only turn into your a blood
an immune system an embryonic type stem
cell can potentially turn into all
that's a pluripotent stem cell our I
don't stem cell multipotent
has a whole lot of things happening in
the stem cell and regenerative enison
field talking about brilliant
transplantation and technologies coming
together one of those exciting things is
we know there's a big shortage of organ
donors many folks died on organ waiting
for an organ and because of motorcycle
helmets and safer cars there are less
healthy donors coming along so one
exciting area we can talk more about is
gene manipulation with CRISPR CRISPR
castañeda yeah definitely and there's
some really exciting work out of George
church's lab at Harvard where they're
now using that to knock in human genes
into pigs
there's miniature swine which are about
human sized and also the ability to
knock out some of the pig immune
proteins that would have you recognize
it as foreign so there's an exciting
feature well we may be having animal
farms
where we'll take a humanized Pig and
take an Oregon a kidney a liver a heart
from that pig to save a human may not be
kosher but but I think folks will take
it yeah there's still some work to go
there but it's it's moving into you know
primate models and maybe a form of organ
donation in the next ten years so going
into genetic engineering this is gonna
be a solid chunk of time that we're
gonna spend there maybe right before we
get there let's talk about what you just
mentioned I feel like within technology
we're working on sometimes a similar
goal but we're doing it in different
ways
certain companies and people are and
those people might not necessarily know
that someone that's doing something in
that's aiming to achieve something in
three years might not be actually doing
it as intelligently for society then
somebody that's maybe doing it in five
or ten years but they're doing it in a
way that is just more intelligent in
general so here's my question that is
with this with you leveraging pigs to
take organs human organs humans human
eyes open eyes in sort of the the look
of the immune markers on that pig liver
will be close enough to human so that
your body won't completely objective so
let's say that this is this three-year
project is this humanized organs or five
however many and then maybe there's this
10-year 20-year project where we're
actually growing the organs the human
organs so now this that's kind of my
question to you is should we be
investing into these with our time and
our money simultaneously or should we
maybe just pump all the energy into the
one that yeah well I think you know
particularly in health and medicine
there's no one often silver bullet and
we need multiple paths for sitting here
in the Innovation Lab at single
University with a bunch of 3d printers
around us there's a lot of interest in
printing organs the idea that you can
replace ink with stem cells or
progenitor x' and some organs are pretty
simple they've been worked from Tony
Atala at Wake Forest and others that
have sort of made 3d constructed almost
printed bladders but those are pretty
simple structures those are sort of
seated with the patient's cells and you
can create in that in a bioreactor
a collagen scaffolding yeah I don't know
all the technical elements but there's
an element of bioengineering and the
donor stem cells and growing it in vitro
and now there have been patients with
these sorts of bioengineered bladders
from Wahb that's a pretty simple organ a
kidney a liver a heart and much more
complex and there's been some pretty
advanced work on doing very printing
blood vessels this companies like
organovo that can you can design on a
computer with computer a design a blood
vessel or a combination the building
block of an organ but if you print an
organ it doesn't have a good blood
supply it's not going to survive in the
recipient the other challenge is really
get any things to function and be at the
size that will work in humans so I think
that's exciting insects attendee of
three depending organs but it may be
that this other technology gene therapy
modifying and humanizing pigs may
leapfrog that and be a much more
streamlined approach interesting no 1
cancer there's no one organ there's no
one set of diseases I mean you may apply
a 3d printing element here however we do
3d printed version of me mini-me is
created here in this laboratory you know
scan me with us this one's much more
good looking at exactly smaller than
doesn't use much that's you know that
would have been magical you know 10-15
years ago I have a 3d printed a company
founded here at singular and out of
singular diversity called made in space
has sent the first 3d printers to the
space station they printed actually this
device a version of it in the space
station and a printed Eva's medical
devices they're the things that would
have felt science fictiony a decade ago
we're here
so in this realm of amazing
Exponential's and 3d printing and stem
cell biology coming together we may see
some amazing advancements in the next 10
years but we're not about to have a 3d
printer again for everybody in the next
two to three years and we're learning
now that diseases are much more defined
at the molecular basis everything from
autism to diabetes to Parkinson's to
Alzheimer's is not just you know type 2
diabetes it may be very different at the
physiologic and metabolic level which
means we have the opportunity to target
it with therapies and Prevention's in
so maybe we talk about a little more
into this silver bullet just because it
seems so attractive right it just does
so the idea of the stage zero medicine
is what you've called it and oh you know
people like Aubrey de Grey have called
it finding pathology at the first
indication of it the formation of the
disease so in that in that idea if the
so could the silver bullet then be a
constant analysis of dynamic state of
the body and then maybe we run AI to
help us understand that and then be able
to give a recommendation right so one
silver bullet is never having to need
the bullet because you're detecting or
preventing disease in the first place
that way when I call that be the bullet
that yes what I call it state zero
medicine the analogy there is you know
I'm a cancer doctor oncologist most
patients present sadly with stage 3 or
stage 4 disease usually meeting advanced
disease it might be spread I might be
large to the point where even the best
chemotherapy and radiation of surgery
may tamp it down but often leads to a
very expensive therapy or in early death
we can pick up disease at stage zero
whether that's a cancer or something
like Alzheimer's before it's clinically
evident we may have the opportunity to
sort of nip it in the bud and
particularly the field of cancer now
there's a lot of interest and how do we
screen for and pick up cancers at stage
zero or one like we've all heard of
potion patients with pancreatic cancer
only discovered at late stage or ovarian
or brain cancers and actually I'm
heading up a new XPrize a new one
focused on early cancer screening so one
of the awesome big challenges in
healthcare is we pay usually for therapy
so there's been many new drugs and
therapies developed for cancers that
very few new screening approaches we
still are stuck with colonoscopy and
mammograms for example there are some
pretty exciting news approaches doing
blood biopsy maybe doing genetic
analysis of circulating tumor DNA and
picking up markers that we can actually
see in our blood as well for some things
like the classic PSA prostate specific
antigen but there's some exciting new
approaches where you might detect
circulating in cancer DNA
and make it really diagnosis but that
still probably requires more expensive
sequencing there's companies like Grail
and guardant and free no more good
examples here in the Bay Area doing some
of those exciting approaches but it's
still probably gonna be a few years
often quite expensive so with this
cancer XPrize we're focusing on
developing a prize maybe fifty million
dollars 100 million dollars or more with
sub prizes where the winning teams will
develop low cost accurate and
democratize able ways of doing early
cancer screening as cheap and easy as a
urine dipstick for pregnancy Wow kind of
for under twenty four dollars under
twenty four hours from Tennessee to
Tanzania that's an aspiration we went
out something that's audacious but
achievable and to catalyze teams from
around the world to forum to approach
that without pre conceived in the
solution it may not be a blood genetic
test to maybe a combination of
ultrasound or a wearable hat to detect
brain tumors or you're in a test that
might with nanotechnology pick up early
cancer molecules in your bottle cancer
in your body so if you go to X PRIZE
comm cancer you can learn more about
this XPrize we're hopefully going to
launch that in late 2018 you can sign up
to get more information and hopefully
we'll crowdsource for this future early
stage zero detection yes now there's
still a chance if we detect something
early what do you do about it
so in many cases you don't want to just
detect that you have really pancreatic
cancer you want to have an approach to
do with it and we want to bring this
around the world because here in the
u.s. most people have access to a
mammogram or colonoscopy even though
many people don't do it when they need
to but in other parts of the world India
rural Africa we have many people dying
who have what would been very
preventable cancers everything's from a
simple cervical cancer to people only
presenting with Braille it's late stage
breast cancer that newer cheaper more
democratized cancer screening could
enable so checkout Express network slash
cancer and maybe join a team so let's
just quickly touch on XPrize just
because I was recently learning about
this from Junoon and obviously Peter
Diamandis is a big proponent of this
sort of of crowdsourcing of the solution
to problems and so the general idea is
that you put out a
it's a problem that needs to be fixed
and then you offer a monetary prize for
the organizations that can solve the
problem and prove that they did and they
have there's so many different but the
prizes across so many different fields
yeah Peter Diamandis the co-founder
singular University really kind of
catalyzed this rebooted the surprise
idea he was inspired by the story of
Lindbergh who crossed the Atlantic not
for fame and glory but to win a monetary
prize it was actually a dollar prize put
out there well when limber acrostic 1923
somewhere should know that history I'm a
pilot I love aviation that's not
actually I know Charles Lindbergh's
great-grandson Erik Lindbergh or
grandson Erik Lindbergh great guy who's
also a pilot has actually recapitulated
his grandfather's flight what was the
prize back then like it was equivalent I
was equivalent of a few million dollars
right yeah inflation that's amazing so
probably about 15 years ago Peter and
others to the XPrize put up this first
prize it was later called the Ansari
XPrize a ten million dollar purse for
the first team that could fly a rocket
to space that wasn't a NASA or a
government agency yeah and that twice in
a we can get to a hundred miles our
hundred kilometers and then I land it as
well in Atlanta so you might remember a
spaceship one that was later I was
actually supported by an amazing team
one it led by Burt Rutan who's a famous
aeronautical engineer funded by Paul
Allen of Microsoft Fame but what the
XPrize had done again back in the
original XPrize for space travel was
catalyzed teams to think how could we
approach this how can we take someone
who's built home build aircraft and
bring this together to solve this
challenge and for that 10 million dollar
prize well ever a few hundred million
dollars was spent and that's now
catalyzed a space industry SpaceX for
example I know Virgin Galactic and Jeff
Bezos and others are really creating
companies that are gonna compete and
maybe even surpass what NASA another
another global agencies have done I love
that so that's a prize model it needs to
be audacious but achievable and
hopefully meet a market failure people
weren't thinking about solving this or
another XPrize was something relatively
straightforward I love those
alliteration good audacious and
achievable but it's hard to design a
prize is audacious that you can want one
other nice example set goals for
yourself personal goals that are both
right and then have the short term that
you need in order to achieve that one
exercise I liked a lot was the will
clean up XPrize after the Big Shell Oil
Spill the the technologies were cleaning
up oil spills hadn't changed in a long
time they're still pretty slow jaesik
powder well I don't think these nets and
scoop it up bottom line not great
technology and so they put out a I think
funded by Wendy Schmidt an oil cleanup
XPrize and teams formed and some of the
winning teams came from completely out
of the side of the oil or clean up and
they more than doubled or quadrupled the
speed and lower the cost of world
cleanup so that's one example and
there's been others so amazing
so there's a whole prize model it can be
leveraged in many fields I helped design
conceived and design a medical tricorder
X Prize so some of you are Star Trek
fans remember bones McCoy
or the equivalent scanning someone with
a what might look like an iPhone today
so we came up with a tricorder X Prize
about seven years ago could we
incentivize teams to create a technology
that could fit your pocket that could do
the job of what doctors would do and
diagnose the top-20 conditions like
heart attack or anti tract infection
pneumonia and I was ten million dollar
prize sponsored by Qualcomm who makes
the chips in our a lot of our phones and
about I think three hundred teams
started the competition they ended up
about ten final it's one of the teams
started right here singing the
University I have one of their little
torta types of what they call the the
the scanner D Scout it was not one of
the winners and they they went through
early clinical trials crowdfunder this
but it's a the idea of a medical
tricorder something you could hold to
your forehead pull down your temperature
your heart rate your oxygen saturation
talk to your smartphone and bedded
without emotional intelligence this
company's going on to do some other
projects but even the teams that sort of
don't win have helped advanced medical
science and this is an example of
convergent technologies the technologies
here that can measure blood oxygenation
or help calculate blood pressure
or pick up temperature may have cost
$10,000 20 years ago but I've gotten
cheaper and Shiva fide and a puff I'd
and with Bluetooth connectivity can now
be something you could manufacture and
put in your pocket for under $100 so I
think the winning team for the trichroic
surprise was started by a emergency
medicine doctor and his engineering
family so you get people thinking out of
the box and taking technologies that
haven't been mashed together and
applying a new lens and I think we'll
have technologies like this in our
pockets who are connected to our
smartphones the next few years so that
you'll use this to do stage you know
medicine to pick up that you have a
urinary tract infection and you get it
treated early or to diagnose that
pneumonia or pick up signs of any number
of elements and then to manage a disease
as well so that's how we do that that's
how we do it that's how we get to the
first goal of finding an identifying
pathology at its first well point things
like that you know the goal you know at
forward though those health centers jump
yeah but they have the Machine where you
just put your fingers in it and then it
senses similar I'm not sure right we're
in this amazing exponential age of
sensing right things that used to
require going into a hospital or a
clinic or an intensive care unit to
measure we can now do with our you know
our smartphones you know there's iPhone
apps now I think Google bought a company
based on Android where the light on your
camera can pick up your oxygen
saturation obviously giving up your
heart rate but now can pick up
hemoglobin your blood level and could be
using the developing world to do screens
for anemia the the microphone on your
smartphone can listen to your cough and
may be diagnosis of pneumonia or pick up
asthma or your pulmonary function and
companies like forward which was started
by a form of I think VPN app at Google I
think how do you redesign the healthcare
system to use some of these tools in the
clinic or at home it might be the
internet of things are connected homes
your bed now can be censored to track
your sleep Apple bought a company that's
doing that I'm wearing a ring right now
called the aura ring out of Finland this
is the original version the new ones
even smaller that can track your sleep
sleep is something pretty important to
your short and long-term health and I'm
sleep deprived at the moment I've got a
little almost two year old keeps waking
at 6:00 a.m. and I'm jet-lagged from
Europe last week but if we can
understand sleep and how might change
that might and they
to pick up disease if your mattress or
your ring or your Fitbit or your Apple
watch can detect that your resting heart
rate which is normally my case 55 starts
creeping up to 70 maybe something's
going on with your heart and lungs you
want to get checked out early and that
might be one signal it may be the year
Amazon echo echo or Google home is
listening to your voice or your cough
it's a hey Dan you know something going
on your bathroom mirror might be picking
up your temperature and picking up they
boy you're getting the flu and may it
let you know that before ii might kick
virals there's a flu epidemic hon right
now as you know for some folks taking
anti varmas and its most shorten the
course so it's an exciting era to get
this data there's issues of privacy who
owns it and then how do you leverage it
for your own self and help prevent
diagnose and treat just quick can you
give us your perspective on the
ownership of the data yeah I mean that's
a topic now there are famous medical
device companies of which will remain
nameless that make pacemakers they do a
great job making pacemakers but if you
were pacemaker that data from that
device is essentially owned by the
company makes it shouldn't you own your
own data from your pacemaker be able to
see it there's been several patients
who've been very engaged in getting
their own data the idea of big and a
turd donor beam going to own your data
and then share it should that belong to
the blood glucose device manufacturer or
the app that connects you to your
SmartWatch I think there's a promise of
being able to own your data and share it
and be smart about the privacy elements
yeah you may not care if someone knows
what your temperature of blood sugar is
you may care if they know your HIV
status or if you're on lithium for a
psychiatric issue the analogy I love to
use is everyone is familiar with Google
Maps and driving with Google Maps are
ways when you drive with your smartphone
as your google map finder it's sharing
your location in your speed and where
you are so that's pretty private data
but would you give up your google map
and the traffic for not sharing that
information you know probably not and if
you think about the future of health
care hopefully it is a bit of a Google
map or ways for health care we're all
sharing some of our date
and hopefully a private secure
anonymized way and could get that map
back of our health trajectory because
you know Alan's health trajectory and
risks and Prevention and they're mine
just like we're driving different cars
and then we might get the opportunity to
choose to choose and to share and
hopefully maybe even be rewarded for
sharing there are companies now that are
enabling you to hopefully maintain and
store your medical data in the
blockchain and they get rewarded for
sharing it exactly there are other
companies now that are collecting data
from any and and and sharing that and
making money from it sometimes famous
story from last week Strava a great
company for tracking your bikes biking
and exercise their data could be mapped
and you can map for people working out
now let's find a map someone running
around Stanford University playing there
now you can see where map sort of the
military might be running around and
places the world where so there's a lot
of potential
Darkseid's downsides but also tremendous
potential if we can unleash the power of
data and I'm a firm believer in many in
the healthcare field that patients
should own their own data have access to
it but and also be able to share it in
smart ways there's also regulations
famous HIPAA health care formation and
privacy and portability act well-meaning
law but now about 20 years old now it's
very hard and many companies and
startups are lit from Sherman based on
well-meaning privacy laws that need to
adapt in this digital age yes and it's
not just your digital health exhaust
from our wearables right it could be
your genome your microbiome your other
omics your expose home you know what
you've lived if you grew up in Beijing
your lung has it your lungs have been a
very different exposure to the front of
world Canada would it be nice if your
primary care doctor knew that and could
use that to better screen your lungs or
other elements so there's a real
challenge to connect the dots between
all this data because if I'm your doctor
I don't want to be getting every hiccup
and blood pressure number from you I
want to get the synthesis of that a bit
of the the check engine light from you
when you're about to blow a gasket not
exactly not when you've had a hiccup
yeah so let's delve a little bit into
what the future of genetic engineering
looks like for Humanity it's been pretty
much everywhere especially since the
CRISPR caste 9 system was innovated and
brought into our world and is still
being played with and is being maybe
played with that a little bit faster
rate in certain countries than in the
United States and maybe what is your
take on the future of course we doing
things like eradicating suffering and
disease we really care about that that's
really important and maybe things like
altering our metabolism to be stronger
or and telling us to be stronger things
like that maybe want wander us down and
maybe the geopolitical situation as well
in terms of how much regulation should
be made of versus not sure well some
technologies we think you know there's
an explosion if I'd say AI right now or
things like 3d printing or robotics and
there's also the the height cycle they
got in her height cycle where things you
know a that's not AI is not a new feel
that's been around for four decades now
in the sense but now it's really
accelerating where it could be applied
and embedded in our in our devices in
our homes and be applied to medicine and
beyond gene therapy is also not a new
area nor gene manipulation but it sort
of been slow to realize its promise many
of the ways of swapping out or embedding
genes
what kind of random it would end sort of
gene randomly into a cell which could be
in a wrong spot which could trigger a
cancer for example and there were
patients who died and in clinical trials
for interesting reasons based on immune
response that now almost that killed the
the gene therapy field like 20 years ago
now when the era only five or six years
since the CRISPR cast 9 approach to gene
editing first in bacteria and then
humans was started and discovered at
Berkeley or an MIT eventing who you talk
to you and that has a lot of excitement
to manipulate human genomics or that of
plants or animals so to cut to the chase
of where that's heading I think is we
have some really good targets for early
gene therapy let's go back to the field
of bone marrow transplantation we talked
about earlier so I'm a I'm trained in
internal medicine pediatrics pediatric
hematology/oncology kids with cancer or
blood disorders and a classic one most
people are heard of a sickle cell
disease
you have one base pair one of those a CT
jeez that's messed up in your hemoglobin
gene and that means often folks of
african-american ancestry who carried
two versions of that gene their cells
the red cells will sickle and they'll
end up with pain crises and damaged
organs and often early death so that's
what a single gene we know where it is
so we now can take out the bone marrow
stem cells these blood-forming stem
cells and using some gene therapy
approaches not always with CRISPR
cassadine there's one they called zinc
fingers come it's like Sangamo and
Bluebird bioscience is studying this
where you can now in early clinical
trials swap out the bad gene for the
good one and read transplant that same
patient with their own now modified stem
cells in their blood an immune system
will reboot and their new red cells are
now normal and they couldn't have long
at normal healthy life that could also
be applied to things like thousand or
HIV there's the famous Berlin patient
who had a bone marrow transplant to cure
his leukemia
yep and artha have HIV he was cured
because the donor stem cells had a
mutation which didn't allow HIV to
propagate across T cells so there's now
looking at fixing the sort of t-cell
genes or the receptors that allow HIV to
to move into the immune system and that
might be a gene therapy approach so
these are single gene diseases we
understand pretty well
Wow if that is the simplest sort of
under sickle cell anemia stuff like this
the single mutation in one gene is
really easily identifiable and curable
is it easy and we'll see potentially
that you need even take out the boomer
stem cells we'll seeing folks of trying
approach vectors where you give the the
gene therapy through a virus or other
vector and it goes to your bone marrow
swaps out the gene and reboots your or
fixes your genetic defect in vivo right
a lot less challenging and taking cells
out there's a lot of excitement in the
cancer field about t-cell immunotherapy
they can call card t-cells which are
very expensive to do now approaches that
are even being done already in China
again China we meet with some some less
regulatory bears in here
they've already been treating patients
with CRISPR cast nine modified t-cells
for me
do you know if they've been successful
with that I don't know the outcomes from
that of course the bigger ethical
challenge is what do we do with diseases
that are multifactorial things like risk
for some cancers cardiovascular disease
they span across a lot of genes right
sometimes so it may not be a simple fix
or what happens when we can use these
approaches to fix
we're not fixed but alter folks before
they're born we're well into the era of
IVF you know millions of folks have been
born in the test tube test tube babies
IV in vitro fertilization now we can
screen embryos for genetic disorders the
the brave new world is a use for that
how do we scream there are ways to take
off one or two cells from a multi cell
embryo after have been fertilized and
grown for a couple days and determine is
it a boy or girls that have I so meet
they're 21 downs but now what happens
when you can select for sex or for eye
color or for intelligence so that's
already on the slippery slope of genetic
ethics now it's already been shown in
the science world that you can modify
embryos with CRISPR cast 9 in in at that
stage so I believe it's still sort of
illegal in the global sense but there's
the possibility to start manipulating
and optimizing or fixing ideally fixing
any vector in minimally it should not be
illegal to fix things that are gonna in
influence suffering on somebody's life
and we don't fix them well there are the
examples of a friend of the family they
had a child with a genetic disorder
Fanconi anemia which can be cured by a
cord blood or a bone marrow transplant
but there were no matches so they had a
another child they want another child
anyway but they selected the child when
it was still an embryo amongst others
that had the genetic match so it could
be a blood donor for the the older
sibling
it was then treated and as a she cured
of an Kony's anemia another genetic form
of hematologic disease so there are
examples of this already the dark side
is what happens we have the genetic
haves and have-nots and folks are
selecting and sort of becoming
evolutionarily more successful there's a
wanderer
down this path a little Oh a great movie
everyone should go watch 20 year old
movies Gattaca and if you've seen
Gannicus yeah we're even Hawk is born
and he's born in the operating room and
immediately his sequenced now we can do
that before you're born yeah and it's
heard of his risk of disease as
propagate and he's a genetic misfit or
not optimized and he has a tough time
pursuing his life goals to be an
astronaut in me and so baking is
genetics with someone else's blood great
movie that gives you insight of what
happens when we can start segregating
folks based on their based genetics or
optimizing their genetic outcome yeah so
so that's a must watch it's a good
perspective yeah and as with many
technologies including AI things are
moving faster than regulatory and ethics
may be able to keep up yeah we're only
what seventeen years into sequencing the
human genome it was several million
dollars or a billion dollars in the 2000
now it's essentially $100 what if I took
your genome right that gets to swab me
right now last month in nature last week
in nature they published there's a
company called I think I on where you
can now sequence it's a shot a USB chip
sized device connected to your laptop No
so for the sake of argument what I could
take your glass of water soak up some of
your a a little bit of DNA sequence you
and publish it online and say hey and we
know that you have these predispositions
you have this risk of XY and Z what
happens if your future employer knows it
you know wow I mean what the size of a
USB flash I plugged into your computer
it's a little pocket-sized device
pocket-sized device Wow
means what can start sequencing our food
our microbiome everything what is that
device doing to the DNA that is that
small how do you actually sequence it's
an ion torrent technology whether these
I won't be able to summarize how but
there's different ways of sequencing DNA
part of it is doing the sequencing
itself other part of the mathematics and
computation of putting together the
pieces these new this new version you do
very long sequences and so we
even look at parts of the dark DNA which
we didn't know what they did or were
hard to sequence in the past and bottom
line sequencing is gonna get very even
cheaper and more ubiquitous companies
like 23andme are allowing you to look at
almost 3 million base pairs and give you
a pretty good look at your ancestry and
your previous mission for certain
diseases or your what might be your eye
color and others but is anyone doing the
dynamic analysis right now your based
you know is should be essentially stable
but then things like proteomics that
kind of write your proteome with the
proteins you know DNA to RNA to protein
that's much more influenced by what
genes are turned on or off your
environment your diet your exposures so
yeah they come well the ability to do
proteomics is getting faster and cheaper
the ability to look at your ex your what
genes are expressed what genes are
turned on or off is never get more
available we can sequence our microbiome
in new ways and understand its role so
we've talked about silver bullet there
won't be any one piece of data it's all
identifying it's not just your it's a
nature nurture right just cuz you have a
gene that gives you a high risk of
breast cancer lung cancer or Alzheimer's
and you gonna get that disease so we're
gonna start to hopefully this field of
system medicine systems biology where
you combine the omics and other
information will give us hopefully
better proactive insight to pick up
disease at stage zero or ideally prevent
it in the first place I can't believe
that someone's just gonna grab my coffee
cup and sequence me and throw me up on
the internet and be like hey yeah well
what if you're running for president
right and what if it showed you at
higher higher risk of developing
Alzheimer's like some may think our
current commander chief may have early
dementia etc we won't get into politics
here but believe me what happens when
candidates have their their digital
footprint or their their biology exposed
what happens when you can target an
individual with a gene therapy or a
virus based on the fact that you have a
particular mutation or a blood type so
there's some good science fiction or
potentially bioterrorism elements that
play into the dark side of this yeah
that's great it's great to raise great
secret either we can kill you kill him
it's so important to at least talk about
these things and become more aware of
them minimally and converse with one
another about how to prevent things like
this from happening bioterrorism but on
the flip side you know this downside
that you're gonna get oh this is playing
God we shouldn't do gene therapy we
shouldn't do molecular biology back in
the early 70s Paul Berg at Stanford who
won the Nobel Prize and we're at Stanley
a helped later found Genentech had the
first technology to splice genes
together that laid the foundation for
companies that companies like Genentech
and others that are have now created
hundreds of drugs that are based on
molecular splicing famous Asilomar
conference and they brought their minds
together and they start to self-regulate
and put up some guidelines just like
we're seeing now in artificial
intelligence an Elon Musk and others are
propagating the the risk side of this so
there's a balance between hopefully
enabling the amazing positive future but
balancing some of the risks just like
drones we have some drones here they can
be used for for good does it also can be
used for for nefarious spying yeah so
even having discourse about the goods
and the bads how to prevent the bats how
to amplify the goods and working
together as a world to identify that so
how do you then work together as the
world with these new technologies no
singular and University doing a pretty
good job at well for you - yeah a part
of a mission is to you know educate
inspire and enable folks to understand
where exponential technologies are where
they're heading and how do you leverage
that for good or also understand some of
the dark sides how do you positively
disrupt the world to address global
challenges from poverty education
healthcare but also to understand the
the negatives and we need our
policymakers in government to understand
the power of existing technologies and
where they're going to be on this
exponential because where will AI and
robotics and 3d printing and nanotech
and and gene editing be in five years
how do Congress by the way the US
Congress only has one member with a PhD
they're not necessarily the sharpest
tools to the box many of them are
lawyers and that's a lawyer's lawyer
litical Paul Ryan has never had a job
aside from being I think a congressional
aide all the way through becoming one of
the scientists that's what's interesting
now a tech special medicine back in
November 2017 two months ago we had two
scientists who are one is Hans cure
stead who is a rare one on stem cell
biologists and researcher running for
Congress in Orange County to flip a red
district and we also had Brian Ford
who's a often in the blockchain and
digital currency world and was in the
Obama administration as a technologist
running for Congress are you getting I
think especially in this midterm era a
lot of folks with a science background
now running for Congress and Senate and
we need some of those Minds there no
matter what party you have some
perspective on once here because the
policies do set now how we remembered in
2001 Bush suppressed embryonic stem cell
research
that's and a lot of us researchers
outside of the us to do embryonic stem
cell research you know that has big
implications if you don't understand the
science the biology and the ethics so we
need to educate global and local leaders
not easy I mean not easy so it is you
know whatever whatever you're learning
you need to look at the the mix of
fields in mix of fields and also get
more people that have science
backgrounds and diverse backgrounds into
Congress so we've talked about a lot of
things and it's been a really solid
session let's end on just a couple quick
thoughts about a couple things it seems
like within maximizing human potential I
think that you care a lot about
healthcare and medicine where do you
kind of see us in five years ten years
and where do you see us going well I'm
an optimist we always but health and
medicine is always a little slower than
we might imagine given the regulatory
challenges like the FDA which is now
actually thinking more exponentially
they have some new progress and digital
health and how do you think about
rigging software as a medical device we
also the challenges in the in a pair
world has an insurance company reward or
paid for gene therapy immunotherapy or a
digital therapy or a wearable
just this last week of this big
announcement from Amazon and JP Morgan
and Brooks are out the way about may be
pretty they're gonna launch a new
endeavor to help fund or sort of cover
their million-plus employees so it's not
about just the technology you can have
the best amazing digital device platform
wearable gene therapy cancer therapy
unless it fits into the healthcare
system someone regulates it someone pays
for it someone prescribes it
someone who checks out the safety
someone figures out how do we speed up
clinical trials you know we're gonna
sort of see we'll still stuck in the era
where we are today with fax machines
being used to communicate a lot of
healthcare data in the United States but
I'm optimistic that my learning
technology and some of these incentives
both from the personal level through our
insurers of everything from the National
Health Service and the in the United
Kingdom to the kaisers and the Blue
Cross Blue Shield's here we can take
some of the technologies here today and
the ones that are coming and help them
converse to address finding disease
early
managing it in smarter more personalized
ways and giving each of us ownership of
our data so we can catalyze that sort of
patients included data donor Google Matt
for healthcare awesome it's such a good
summary so what about a item for people
that are watching right now just
something to do it can it can be related
to healthcare may be going out and
getting yourself sequence may be or may
be something else about how they can
maximize their potential regarding their
goals or their focus or the family or
well-being what would be something that
you recommend sure I mean if we think
about healthcare today particularly in
the developed world it's really much
more sick care we're kind of waiting for
disease to happen the heart attack the
stroke the cancer sure of our own
personal health and wellness is to be
more proactive and more continuous so if
you can start to track your sleep with a
cheap wearable and begin extra half an
hour of sleep if you can use your
SmartWatch or smartphone to give you
some insight and how many steps you are
doing and maybe take the stairs instead
of the elevator these small changes and
self nudges that are hopefully tuned
your own personality
can make a big difference long-term so I
would encourage folks to be a little
more proactive to hopefully start to
play with their healthcare data to learn
how to influence themselves to stay on
the healthier side of the spectrum and
again it concerns be simple elements and
then also to help catalyze the future by
connecting that data to their health
care team I've got a the Apple watch
here and a good example of a cool
technology is this is this can record an
EKG company called alivecor if you have
atrial fibrillation sometimes a regular
rhythm wouldn't be nice if you can check
that and send that information to your
doctor or the phone will do that will do
the diagnostics that's on the market
today you can find on Amazon
many patients discover this and educate
their cardiologist about it Wow
or if you have high blood pressure you
can buy a connected blood pressure cuff
online or an Apple store etc and use
that to help self manage and then share
that data with your clinical team so a
lot of it isn't about new technologies
about owning the data understanding it
not just data but information and being
part of catalyzing some progress which
often doesn't come from the policymakers
and the insurance companies it can be
sometimes from the grassroots yeah I
hang you within the self well within the
self and connecting the dots one short
story we had a tech specialness in this
year an amazing woman named Jennifer
Brea who has was diagnosed with chronic
fatigue syndrome when she just finished
her PhD in our documentary yeah it's
called unrest unrest film calm watch the
film I think it's available online and
this book and it this is a patient
population that's hard to get energized
because they're often stuck in bed and
it's hard to often be believed by the
medical establishment one of the
questions that we ask a lot on our show
is that we like to ask people if we if
they think that we're alone in the
cosmos what do you think I've always
been a space junkie
there's you know there's the it's well
known that there are what millions
billions of galaxies out there
and several what's the famous law about
the odds of a of a single planet having
life it's a bit naive for us to think it
only happened here Drake Drake Equation
right the math there's pretty profound
that it's like 1 in every 5 stars has a
habitable planet orbiting it right so um
I'm not a big set you know I love the
study movie and thinking about it but I
don't think we're probably alone the
universe given how it seems biology
might work it may not be same
carbon-based life-forms that we're
imagining maybe others and you know that
we always think we should have seen
signs of them by now maybe some people
think we have maybe there's a danger of
self extinction from nuclear or others
yeah but I think we're probably not
alone yeah Paul Shapiro told me that
what a waste of space that B might be so
you know and then alright how about are
we in a computer simulation well we're
the quarters I have to keep feeding the
machines keep the lights on well one of
the fascinating areas of technology and
health the final protein of the brain is
trying to understand what is
consciousness and then because we're
just sort of seeing each other we don't
in a representation that our brain
perceives right there's amazing work by
David Eagleman and others where you can
take in senses through your back you
know if you're deaf
not just or through your tongue so how
we perceive the world is interesting and
then is it a simulation I'd like to
think not but for those you like to play
sin city you know if you are just some
elements of a big video game somewhere I
don't feel like I'm simulated I used to
be elated where the quarters so then
your stance on freewill is I told great
I'm not a pocket philosopher but at my
free will I I would hope we all have
some free will but we're also
constrained by our biology the human
condition as well as sometimes our you
know our evolutionary elements you know
how do we integrate in society what is
racism what is tribalism so that is
somewhat wired into us from our
evolutions
plain is that free well now are we sort
of driven biologically there's great
examples of folks committing crimes
sometimes atrocious crimes and then
they've done the biopsy on their on
their brain and they have a big tumor
were they legally responsible for that
so sometimes those may not be exactly
will you're driven by er you know we're
[ __ ] see off the chart hormones from
the from the tumor but I think we should
still take personal responsibility and
behave as if we yeah all do have
ultimate responsibility and and can
educate our kids and society to have
that mindset yep and so what would you
say is the most beautiful thing in the
world
okay well I've got three little kids two
little kids well yeah that's a beautiful
thing you see yeah you know the eyes of
your you know one year old and you know
the miracle of life is still always a
good window to end with and then
appreciating nature and sunrise and
presence in our digital age it's easier
to get more connected but be more
disconnected to that so I think there's
a bit of a movement now to recognize the
impact on our brains of some of these
technologies that might keep us away
from beauty might keep us super
connected and have lots of Twitter
followers but not necessarily be as
ingrained with our our souls and our our
friends and family and and seeing the
beauty around us yep so you mentioned
kids a second ago I have another
perspective on that which is that you
people really like their kids because
they see themselves and that's
biologists that's Bob are our simulation
yeah exactly so how much do you think
last thing how much do you think that
genetics is going to take a higher role
than mimetics and the communication of
ideas
in the future meaning as in people are
starting to identify
mimetics as something that is so
important to them that the communication
and dissemination and getting people
inspired by ideas and kind of baiting
people together around that is maybe
more important than doing things like
having kids and spending so much energy
on children hmm
yeah there's a big biological and
economic cost to have children but
there's still our future I think yeah
leaves today in 2018 not everybody
obviously probably one of the two but
where do you where do you see that you
know the future having kids might be
quite interesting because it there's
actually work published the last couple
of years by Allen flake is a pediatric
surgeon of UPenn where you can
essentially have an artificial pink
placenta and and womb and they've grown
sheep essentially would have been very
preterm in a test tube and essentially
bad bad summary but you know how we have
kids in the future might be quite a bit
different and may be that you go online
combine your your sequenced genome with
with a partner and never actually have
to do the gestation crazy we can think
about our digital kids right now that we
can collect all this information about
us figure out simulations we could
simulate you or me based on voice it's
already apps that I have in my
smartphone that can manipulate your face
and make you animated and smile and
laugh it's awful videos real right so
what happens then what if we bottle
ourselves as their clone not a can't
tell if that's actually you during test
all that stuff is here or coming quickly
in different ways so the future of
having kids future of Health's panelling
Sheva tea which we didn't touch has a
lot of ethical and other things that
would take a whole another hour to
discuss that I don't know the answers do
well that'll be for our next time it'll
definitely dive into some of those
things because there's so much more to
unpack here I really appreciate everyone
tuning in again we were with Daniel
craft this is simulation we are very
grateful to have Ron Vargas killing it
on the TriCaster doing incredible
direction
directing work again you can find us on
patreon please support us do you like
this content give it a like give a share
give it a comment tell us what you think
about it on patreon you'll get access to
all of our guests ahead of time you'll
get access to exclusive content you'll
get priority and asking our guests
questions and you'll get access to
events ahead of time so there's a bunch
of great perks of becoming a patron with
us and again thank you so much for
tuning in we do have a upcoming event it
is actually sold out on the 17th with
Jordan Peterson it's gonna be a really
great event and we are looking to
potentially do a another one with him
but that's we'll figure it out we'll see
where that goes on that same weekend
we'll see but and we'll open that up as
soon as possible to everyone and again
thank you for tuning in Daniel thank you
so much for joining us thanks Ryan been
an absolute blast
thank you Cheers